Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Deep Learning means that we are working with
neural networks that contain many inner layers.
As neurons in each layer combine information
from the layer before, the deeper we go in
these networks, the more elaborate details
we're going to see.
Let's have a look at an example.
For instance, if we train a neural network
to recognize images of human faces, first
we'll see an edge detector, and as a combination
of edges, object parts will emerge in the
next layer.
And in the later layers, a combination of
object parts create object models.
Neural texture synthesis is about creating
lots of new images based on an input texture,
and these new images have to resemble, but
not copy the input.
Previous works on neural texture synthesis
focused on how different features in a given
layer relate to the ones before and after
it.
The issue is that because neurons in convolutional
neural networks are endowed with a small receptive
field, they can only look at an input texture
at one scale.
So for instance, if you look here, you see
that with previous techniques, trying to create
small-scale details in a synthesized texture
is going to lead to rather poor results.
This new method is about changing the inputs
and the outputs of the network to be able
to process these images at different scales.
These scales range from coarser to finer versions
of the same images.
Sound simple enough, right?
This simple idea makes all the difference
- here, you can see the input texture, and
here is the output.
As you can see, it has different patterns
but has very similar properties to the input,
and if we zoom into both of these images,
we see that this one is able to create beautiful,
high-frequency details as well.
Wow, this is some really, really crisp output.
Now, it has to be emphasized that this means
that the statistical properties of the original
image are being mimiced really well.
What it doesn't mean is that it takes into
consideration the meaning of these images.
Just have a look at the synthesized bubbles
or the flowers here.
The statistical properties of the synthesized
textures may be correct, but the semantic
meaning of the input is not captured well.
In a future work, it would be super useful
to extend this algorithm to have a greater
understanding of the structure and the symmetries
of the input images into consideration.
The source code is available under the permissive
MIT license, so don't hold back those crazy
experiments.
If you have enjoyed this episode and you think
the series provides you value or entertainment,
please consider supporting us on Patreon.
One-time payments and cryptocurrencies like
Bitcoin or Ethereum are also supported, and
have been massively successful, I am really
out of words, thank you so much.
The details are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!